this is the theme bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be
unto you
I may be your host of the Deen show and
you've come to the right place to learn
about Islam and Muslims and we're going
to be talking a little bit today about
the verbatim word of god almighty the
quran when we come back here on the Deen
show sit tight
this is the thesis bethey
this is the thing this is the thing
I'll sit out Malik Oh
peace be unto you how are you doing my
brother are they fine
that's man can so you heard me introduce
as many others did that we're going to
be talking today a little bit about the
verbatim Word of God the crap
yes now one of the incredible miracles
is that millions upon millions have
memorized the verbatim Word of God the
Koran and you're one of those people is
that correct yes God is yeah this is
great and what age did you memorize the
crowd I started memorizing when I was 11
and I completed it when I was 13 so it
took you how about two years the first
year I did it along with my schooling so
I was in Greek six or seven I don't
remember and then the second year I went
full-time so I dropped the school as
well just to focus on memorization now
some people who aren't really thinking
about this and we say it's a miracle
they say what's the big deal what is the
big deal about someone actually or
millions being able to memorize this
book the beauty behind this specific
book itself is I find that it's hard for
anyone to memorize any other book of any
book in in that case and the beauty
behind memories in a font I never knew
Arabic when I memorized it so memorizing
a book which consists of about 800 pages
of a language that we don't even speak
that itself is a miracle and you know
Lee besides memorizing the translation
and memorizing anything that's in
English 800 pages and not only that it's
another miracle behind the memorization
of the Quran is the fact that we're able
to remember it so for about 15 years in
the month of Ramadan for 15 years I've
been leading the
people have been leading the
congregation in the taraweeh prayer that
Arabic prayer is a prayer that we would
pray at night and we recite the whole
Quran through memory so I mean only if
you're you have memorize the Quran or a
half uh that they call it it's easy to
understand that the Quran itself is a
miracle not only reading it and
memorizing it and also remembering this
so it's been years now but I still
remember the Quran and I can code versus
if you were to ask me I would be able to
just to give you a versus just off the
top of my head so we're not talking
about all the scientific facts today
that I mentioned the development of the
human being in the embryo the mountains
the Seas the water cycle those are
miracles and signs themselves for the
sincere humble person who wants to know
the truth
God Almighty has put hundreds of signs
in this Quran but this is the sign that
we're talking about today that people
not only has it been preserved since
1400 years ago when it was revealed but
has been memorized this is very deep it
is a big deal yeah and the reason they
stressed I'm memorizing it is the whole
idea of the preservation of the Quran
how from the beginning of time there's a
lot of I mean through the books of
history we can see that there's a lot of
people they couldn't read or write so
the only way they would preserve
something if I remember eight of my men
by memorizing it so 1400 years ago when
the Quran was being revealed to Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him until this
day this habit of memorizing the Quran
has has just been there and usually any
individual would want someone in the
family to be a Hopf whether someone was
memorize the Quran a half way this is
someone we call who has memorized
so it's being preserved in the hearts
and the minds of the people and that's
why we still have the message in time
because we know the previously revealed
books we don't have the originals right
they've been changed corrupted and we
don't have them today but we have the
Koran exactly we have the Quran just the
way it was revealed that's exactly how
we've had how we have it that is very
deep if someone is a thinking person who
analytically scientifically approaches
this right and he looks at just this
miracle children you said you were at 11
but aren't there kids at a younger age
who memorized this whole book it was I
the memorization of the Quran and the
youngest person youngest child was
memorize with me was 7 yeah 7 7 years
old and he's still funky sometimes and
and we're not talking about the English
the English is not the Quran this is
Arabic we're talking just pure Arabic
Arabic words of the Quran as you know
maybe all also a few verses that's what
we want to get into next we want the
sincere humble person to hear this is
the speech of God and now you're going
to be we're going to ask you some
questions God willing and you straight
from the verbatim word of God it's going
to be from the verbatim Word of God
you're gonna recite this so you might
not understand what he's saying
we're trying to gonna we're going to try
to have the the meaning there in the
English but if you open your heart this
will penetrate if you're looking for the
truth you you so will recognize it so
let's talk about Allah who's not a man
or a woman he's not the son of the moon
but he's the creator of all these things
in creation he's the one guy right the
one creator so tell us a little bit
about Allah what he says about himself
and the verbatim were to be on the Quran
in the Quran Allah Himself says
bismillah ar-rahman ar-rahim voila I had
a lot of Adam you did what amulet what a
Michael De Luca for when I had the
meaning of these verses it's that all
profits upon wounded message was
revealed say that Allah is one and
there's nothing equal to him he he does
not have any parents nor does he have
any children and there is nothing
similar to Allah so this is um this is a
is a surah or a chapter of the Quran
which basically encircled er covers all
aspects and every any question that you
can have about Allah considering that
Allah does not need anyone working with
him he is not a parent he's not a child
and he also he is free from any human
help in any way shape or form let's move
on to another verse from the Quran that
describes a little bit about the creator
of the heavens and the earth Allah
another verse of the Quran there are
numerous verses actually right from the
beginning wait till the end but another
verse that's coming to my head right now
and go ahead and put put some put some
put some of the beautiful tone of
recitation that you have I will into it
another verse as I said there are many
many verses but what's coming to my mind
is specific a specific set of verses
were in which Allah talks about himself
and his qualities this when there are
many more he who Allah would lead
you know allahu allah ma ma ma sha allah
rahman al rahim allah la ilaha ill allah
al malikul oh do so ceremony no
Mujahideen Oh Aziz orientable motorcade
Billy
super Hannah law Mary whoo-hoo Allah
holiday pudding body animal so we all
avoid asthma will host man you said be
home a piece a my word he was ugly well
I see he's with hockey and these verses
a lot is telling mankind that that he is
Allah the one who is worshipped
thereafter Allah is telling different
qualities of Allah the one who is free
from all defects the one who is the
giver of security the one who watches
over you the one who is almighty the one
who is hearing everything that you do
the one who sees that we think that you
do and other qualities that are
mentioned in in these specific verses
similarly Allah in the in the final
verse says that he is Allah who all of
the good qualities belong to him the
qualities of completion of the qualities
of in completion completion meaning to
be to be good or to be able to hear
everything you know to be able to see
everything these are all considered
qualities of completion in completion is
more to life that's something which is
incomplete so all the qualities of
completion belong to Allah and and then
loves Ronald other finishes these verses
by basically saying that everything in
the heavens and the earth the praising
and he is the one who was just the
Almighty and the all-wise so these
verses are very beautiful perfect
perfection no deficiency notification
and that's the creator of the heavens
and earth Allah there's a very one of
the most powerful verses in the Quran I
eat okra see can you go ahead and recite
this manual or la la la la playa la food
ojos en 800 Ida no Lahoma fils-aime ha
you wanna fill out melodious pero en la
vie give me llamo marina a medium one
for the family whatever you wanna be
c'est la vie Masha was the aqwal see you
Sam Hawaii well um what are you doin
well Nadia now the briefly go ahead and
just summarize this powerful verse a
very powerful verse indeed Allah is
basically a la savant Allah is telling
us that Allah granted a deal and what I
offer you that there is no other god but
Allah there's no one you would worship
except Allah and he is the one who is is
alive and the one who was always there
he will never he will never fall asleep
not even falling asleep but you know you
know he doesn't rest on the 6th day he
doesn't take a nap none of these things
none of these things and the way the way
Allah said in this verse to sing I don't
know what I know the words sing I
thought in Arabic means it's not sleep
but you know what you're really tired
you start to get drowsy yeah exactly
that's what none of them that doesn't
even get close to it with yeah and I'm
not even close to it yeah that the whole
of us in heaven would I know
yeah mama Boehner ad mama - he knows
what's in front of you he know
behind behind you he knows what's there
before you you know what's there after
you he knows basically the whole
knowledgeable he knows everything that's
there about you with you anything to do
with you he's the God yes he is Allah
and again it's all about perfection all
about just as you know if you want to
see perfection you won't find it in the
world but you will find it with Allah
with the Creator that happens in earth
and we'll be right back with more here
on the Deen show I don't say to people I
used to be a Christian I still carry the
values and principles of loving Jesus
Christ and perhaps we may be more than
themselves Christians so I think I got
the best out of Christianity by becoming
Muslim so many other things that you can
enjoy without drinking a sip of alcohol
this is the same thing it's not an
obstacle it's not something to cause
people to get completely desperate and
start talking living their lives no it
should be a motivation it's only one
life that you're gonna be living so you
better do it for the last channel
without it
I'm not alone I am NOT alone I am NOT
alone I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid
back here on the Dean show and we are
talking with a gentleman our brother who
has memorized the verbatim Word of God
the Koran and we're giving you the not
yet Muslims a Muslim is one who has
chosen to submit him or herself
completely to the will of God doing
God's thing not your own thing doing
what God Almighty wants you to do so
that's a Muslim so we want the not-yet
Muslims and the Muslims to get to
understand and appreciate this book the
Quran a little better so we have our
brother reciting it a little bit so they
can go ahead and hear some of the
verdict and the verses and we cover it a
few verses on the description of the
creator is perfect perfection far from
any deficiency now let's talk about this
mighty messenger Jesus peace be upon him
because it's not a confusion about him
and people don't know that we love Jesus
you can't be a Muslim unless you believe
in Jesus that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of God but he never
called people to worship himself he
never called people to any of these
things he called people to the worship
of the one god
so let's go ahead please can you recite
the story of Jesus peace be upon him in
the verbatim word of God the Quran I'm
thinking of a few verses here but what's
coming to our mind is specific set of
verses that appear in and the chapter of
Mary there's a chapter named Mary this
is the mother of Jesus yes this is not
even in the Bible they don't have a
chapter named after his mother but we do
it's in the crown chapter 19 chapter 19
it's called Mary and when the most when
the Muslims according to the story and
when they were looking for you know when
they were being persecuted they had
they moved out from Mecca and they went
to Ethiopia and they were looking for
some type of safely over there and they
were predominantly questions over there
so when they had you know they had asked
them the question was specifically what
is your belief in Jesus or what does
they believe in Mary so one of the
companions of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he recited a few bruises I mean
ever sent over selection please granite
miss Mandela rahmani raheem one of kulfi
nakita mo am eating Taba that mimic a
novelty factor for that meal doing him a
job Thomson Eliyahu Hanavi masala dhaba
shavanasa we all it in need who do
bulimia
all in an aerosol or avec la Habana he
would Hammond Zaki Paulette and Nicole
Julio de jambe MSS Mombasa Madame Hecuba
de paula cada equipo de goochie goo hara
dhania one inaudible in Saguaro mataman
walkin and prom happily muhammad who
fell debe that rahim I can encode
Mohammed who fell Taba that Bahama
cannon Vasya fragile Mahal in a jittery
Knopfler oh let ya later NEMA Taco Bell
had work
Donetsk MNC funada minute active and
Anthony Padilla de Vaca tactic II said
II
wahoo CIBC drain a flirty to say take a
banana
Sakuni wasabi wanna say in Metairie in
nominal specially
suppori in Neenah doctoral Rahman in
Solman Fallon vocally manana in Syria
fajitas fajitas Omaha tomato oh no Yama
Yamada petition
Fatiha yeah Donna Mercado Kim processor
in Canada body fat
Eliyahu - okay any woman can film a
hobby
hola Guinea are badula Italian akita
watarigani Navi
waha Danny Mubarak and avocado mousse on
evil saw that he was a demon - hiya
wobble lumpy wa rida t1a me Ajay Anita
Baron Satya was Adam where are they
Yamuna Wooley
- why Omaha Motoman uber are too high
so these verses basically having to do
with the birth of Jesus and his
miraculous birth and about the they call
it the holy ghost that came and blew the
soul into the womb of Mary and she
conceived and the baby was born and how
the baby had talked right in you know in
a young age infancy
now so someone might not get confused
you got your Holy Ghost
some
were believe in the Holy Trinity Father
Son Holy Ghost this have anything to do
with that this has nothing to do as we
know as Muslims we believe and maybe
maybe I said it wrong as Holy Ghost oh
we would we I mean basically the way
Allah said in the Quran he ordered the
Archangel Jimmy Dean to come down and
blow the soul into the woman Mary so
that was the angel Gabriel now the angel
Gabriel on the command of the Creator to
have undermined of the creator gotcha
okay so we're gonna take a break and
we'll be right back with more you're on
the Dean show
there always be someone that'll be there
to say something negative but at the
same time there'll be someone there to
say something positive awesome just hold
onto the Rope of Allah everything in
this universe can rely I need a last
minute the Quran says don't kill women
don't kill children don't feel old
people don't attack the civilians this
is what the Prophet Muhammad told us if
you're famous you know Allah said that
the Prophet SAW shall have never ever
stopped a war against any
Salam alaikum peace be unto you we're
here with our brother share mathematic I
was memorizing the verbatim word of God
the Quran and we're letting you get a
taste of it letting you hear the
recitation of the speech of God save
preserved edit free at it proof tamper
free tamper proof not the words of
Muhammad not the words of a man but
these are the actual words at the crater
that happens in earth now tell us
clearly is this book without any doubt
does the creator of the heavens and
earth does he say that they're very good
question and the answer to that question
is right in the first chapter of the
Quran in the first verse where Allah he
says an oversight over all over set them
for you miss women are very delicate a
Buddha ffe
could intervene and levena you mean
abilify BYUtv muna saw that one in
multiple moon when Lady and Iranian
public wobble has a rotten immune well
he can either of them mirror of being
him what would he care whom Allah mostly
home on these verses the first verse
actually starts off by Allah telling
mankind that this is a book in which
there is no doubt not at all
that's the first verse no doubt in it no
doubt at all and
it brings up another verse where Allah
says in the Quran I fell yet about moon
and over and what okay I mean are you
related he that watcheth fifty deaf and
Cathy or or Allah is basically telling
mankind that do they not ponder upon the
Quran that there is no doubt in it
because if this was a word that belonged
to anyone else you would find a lot of
mistakes and a lot of differences that
you would find so the Quran beginning to
the end I memorize it when I was young I
know people that have just recited the
Quran have seen seeing guidance through
it and the reason is that it is a
miracle every part of it as a miracle
just reciting the Arabic not knowing the
translation as I had said earlier is a
miracle preserving it this way as a
miracle and just just normal facts of
life as we can see as the verses that I
had recited everything is to do what the
Quran is just so beautiful and it's it's
perfection perfection to the limit of
perfection that you can't find anything
wrong with it you can't find here you
can't question it amazing I'd like to
thank you we're out of time for taking
the time to be with us and letting us
hear the verbatim Word of God from you
I got Almighty Allah rewards you thank
you and I enjoyed being around long
thank you peace be on to you and thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Deen show and you've gotten to hear
the verbatim word of God the Quran this
is a speech of God so if you love God I
mean if you really love God then take a
timeout and read this book read the
Quran read the Quran and see for
yourself but you've got to have an open
heart and open mind you've read every
other book out there pick this book up
you can call the number on the screen 1
800 662 Islam you get it for free
cost you nothing sit in the morning have
a nice cup of coffee a cup of tea and
pick up the translation of the meaning
and just read with the sincere intention
wanting to get close to God wanting the
guidance take it from there and see what
happens and we'll see you next time here
and the Dean show until then peace be
unto you he created the universe he is
the first his messengers to all these
creatures of the great danger Oh
worshipping other than Allah
there is none greater
the Creator there is none greater
reah
I am Not Afraid you stand alone if a box
by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone I
am Not Afraid